Maybe I'll just wait over here
What's up guys, we are Pongfinity
We are back with another episode of challenge Pongfinity
Our special guest today is Keisha
She's not very good at tricks
but she's here just to show her pretty face
This video is sponsored by Raycon
whose wireless earbuds we'll talk more about later on
Okay so is it possible to play with a
needle
Needle was quite on point there but not
enough
Dropshot, smash
You can really feel that something has struck the ball
You wont expect this..
Had a bit of a rush there
This is my way to do it
Okay what's happening?
Lets try playing on Otto's shoulders
Let's go!
For once you don't have to worry about
footwork
Someone else is doing it for you!
We are unbeatable!
Where's the footwork Otto!
Maybe I should be the one below
Yeah you should
So for the next challenge we need a target
The one who spins a different colour rubber, loses
No!  I knew it!
I get to eat some bubble gum so I guess I'm the real winner here!
Not bad!
We have to do slight modifications to the net
Just put it like this
Bit of an operation
There it is!
Thats pretty good!
I'm surprised that we got it so well
Looks quite good!
This is some creative video shooting
Maybe I'll just wait over here
That was a roller!
The table is suitable for around the nets
I'm sure you didn't expect that
Found the technique now
Apparently yeah
Raycon is a wireless audio technology brand
whose earbuds start at about half the price of other premium wireless earbud brands
The audio quality is great!
And are also perfect for practicing
This is the latest model,  E 25
with six hours playtime
It also comes with a handy charging case
It's also suitable for around the nets!
So go to buyraycon.com/pongfinity
to get 15% off your order
Brought to you by Raycon
Big thanks to sponsoring this video!
Thank you Keisha you've been a great help today
Don't forget to hit subscribe
and watch our previous videos.
Until next time! Keisha you're supposed to say until next time!